cours desquelles
la tension a été en priorité accordée à
ce qui avait été déjà discuté entre le
premier ministre draghi le président
poutine il ya une compréhension que nos
dirigeants sont intéressés à la
poursuite de telles discussions
et envisager toutes les possibilités de
discuter avec nos collègues italiens
nous avons noté une bonne évolution dans
nos relations bilatérales
et le volume des échanges l'an dernier a
augmenté de 50 % l'année dernière pour
atteindre 30 milliards de dollars et les
milieux d'affaires ont de bonnes
relations et en janvier dernier il ya
une réunion entre le président poutine
et les entrepreneurs et à liart par
visioconférence
au sein dans le cadre des échanges entre
les chambres de commerce et d'industrie
et nous espérons pouvoir reprendre
bientôt les travaux
en présence réelle donc de nos groupes
de travaux puisque pendant la période de
pandémie un certain nombre de mécanismes
ont connu une certaine baisse et nous
voudrions reprendre l'activité des
consultations intergouvernementales qui
était largement utilisée encore
récemment
et et en 2013 il ya vu donc à trieste
les dernières rencontres de ce type donc
des consultations qui sont en fait un
forum des deux dirigeants avec tous les
membres du gouvernement
et ce mécanisme était tout à fait utile
et malgré les restrictions liées au
corona virus en 2020
le temps passe vite mais
donc il ya vu dans le format de +2 au
niveau des mises affaires étrangères à
des ministres de la défense des
rencontres et nous pensons sérieusement
à organiser une prochaine réunion qui
devrait se tenir en italie
aussi pour les échanges culturels et
entre nos deux pays ces échanges suscite
un très grand intérêt chez nos citoyens
en
septembre dernier il y avait eu donc le
lancement des années croisées à milan et
ce programme d'échangé culturel est très
important il va s'achever à la fin de
cette année et nous justement justement
nous travaillons à
poursuivre ces échanges pour les années
2000 23 2025 donc nous avons noté aussi
les 200 ans de la naissance de
dostoïevski et
l'inauguration d'un monument et nous
avons bien compris que nos deux cultures
était tout à fait complémentaires et
d'un héritage historique et culturel qui
est très important sur les affaires
étrangères international la première
thématique a discuté aujourd'hui c'était
celle de l'euro atlantisme et des
problèmes que
la fédération de russie a identifié dans
sa lettre adressée aux états unis et à
l'otan
avec la proposition de mener des
discussions concrètes sur des garanties
juridiques contraignantes
qui garantirait une c'est la sécurité
pour la russie nous avons reçu une
réaction de ces initiatives nous avons
attendu pendant un mois et demi et
ja chef justement l'analyse de la lettre
envoyé par les américains est très
prochainement vous saurez comment la
situation va évoluer en tout cas
aujourd'hui nous
adressons une lettre à la partie
américaine et c'est déjà prévenu que
cette lettre sera rendue publique nous
considéraient qu'il est absolument
nécessaire
que
tous les membres des
communautés civiles de société civile de
nos pays sous intéressés de ceux qui
émanent de chaque pays autrement si cela
est maintenue dans le secret comme le
veulent nos collègues de washington et
bruxelles à ce moment là l'opinion
publique
sera perdue au sein parmi tous les
messages les mensonges et la propagande
médiatique sur ce qui se produit
aujourd'hui en europe en particulier à
la frontière entre la russie et
l'ukraine et en tant que professionnel
où
vous savez très bien dans quelle mesure
on peut croire ou ne pas croire les
médias et bien entendu nous avons
exposé notre vision sur l'avenir de
notre coopération
multi polaire dans les différents
formats
que ce soit les relations russie une ou
deux le conseil russie otan qu à
l'époque où il travaillait en tout ou
bien au sein de l'eau et c'est eux
ou nous intervenons tradi seulement en
faveur d'un dialogue
contre la tentative de certains pays
membres de l'oie ceux de se servir de
cette plateforme comme d'un
vecteur de confrontation et d'une
manière générale pour la paix en europe
nous voyons une course une
continuation du rôle qui a été jouée par
l'italie en
2002 lors du
sommet de pratica di mare et qu' une
déclaration appelait justement à la
pègre et concrétisait
une feuille de route de ce qui était
alors qualifié de partenariat et qui
pouvait devenir donc un partenariat
stratégique que nous sommes très
reconnaissants à notre collègue luigi di
maio et à sa délégation pour les
initiatives qu'ils ont manifesté de
venir en visite en russie c'est toujours
utile de discuter surtout dans ces
situations quand
rien ne remplace une une rencontre
directe pour pouvoir s'exprimer très
clairement sans aucune ambiguïté je vous
remercie
merci
merci à tout le monde
je suis content d'avoir la plus
opportuniste et de visiter moscou et de
discuter avec monsieur lavrov je
voudrais le remercier
pour cet accueil pour la conversation
que nous avons eue aujourd'hui nous
avons en effet
toujours considérer la russie comme un
pays avec lequel nous avons des liens
forts dans le domaine économique et
d'autre ce sont ces liens qu nous donne
la possibilité de mener une discussion
franche
notamment sur des questions sur
lesquelles nos opinions divergent
aujourd'hui la réunion a été assez
profonde à mon avis nous avons
évoqué la situation en ukraine
nous allons continuer à travailler dans
ce contexte
je voudrais souligner que
je veux également le souligner dans mes
conversations avec d'autres
interlocuteurs que la russie représentée
par monsieur lavrov a souligné
qu'elle était prête à chercher des
moyens de sortir de cette crise
j'ai entendu les mêmes déclarations de
me manque collègues à kiev monsieur
collègues donc nous pouvons voir qu'il y
a des qui a des volontés de continuer à
chercher une solution diplomatique
c'est une solution diplomatique qui
devrait prévaloir parce que
sinon des conséquences pour le continent
européen seront graves et imprévisibles
voilà pourquoi un autre avis nous devons
suivre ce trajet le trajet qui nous mène
à la paix et à la stabilité
les forces militaires devraient céder
leur place un dialogue pour réaliser cet
objectif nous devons
comme vous savez depuis ces dernières
semaines et il y a eu des contacts entre
des contacts téléphoniques entre
monsieur draghi le président du
gouvernement italien
est aujourd'hui cette réunion que j'ai
avec monsieur lavrov se sont tous des
signes que nous considérons ne perce pas
perspective d'une manière positive
nous avons en espoirs particulier
suscité par le fait que les deux pays
ont été d'accord pour organiser
la visite du premier ministre en russie
marc ce mardi lors de la réunion avec
monsieur collet bas
le par la partie ukrainienne a exprimé
son opinion se disant préoccupé
fortement comme l'ensemble du continent
européen et comme l'italie également
l'italie soutient la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
nous sommes persuadés qu'il faut
trouver un moyen
de pour éviter une
escalade nous allons travailler pour
mettre en oeuvre des accords de minsk en
pratique dans le domaine de la sécurité
tout comme dans les questions politiques
nous allons
continuer à accorder notre assistance au
processus dit normandie dans le cadre du
format dit normandie
aux activités de leurs leaders nous
apprécions les efforts de la russie dans
ce sens
la réponse qu'a évoqué monsieur lavrov
c'est une bonne nouvelle il s'agit de
cette réponse à la proposition
occidentale
et je voudrais souligner que
tout ça nous donne l'espoir
qu'une bonne perspective des relations
entre la russie l'union européenne
les possibles la réunion d'aujourd'hui a
servi d'opportunité
excellente pour échanger avec nos
collègues c'est encore une brique
apporté à la base de ses bonnes
relations avec entre le pays que
monsieur lavrov a mentionné nous sommes
persuadés que tout cela contribuera à la
réduction des tensions et l'italie a été
et reste toujours un pays de dialogue je
vous remercie chers collègues nous
passons aux questions
l'agent ce rallye
celle du panier correspondant de rails
première question est pour le ministre
dit maya
quelle est la position de l'italie si
les sanctions à l'égard de la russie ces
deux nouvelles sanctions sont
introduites et pour monsieur lavaud fin
le 20 février se termine les exercices à
la frontière avec la biélorussie cela
veut-il dire que c'est la fin d'une
escalade
enfin des questions brèves
sinon
c'est la demande
la position de l'italie à
la diffuse je voudrais dire que la
position italienne sur les sanctions est
bien connu depuis longtemps
l'italie c'est un membre de l'alliance
et non
partageons cette décision commune dans
le cadre de la communauté nous cherchons
des moyens de choisir une réponse
diplomatique pour éviter la
confrontation
oui nous savons que il existe la règle
du consensus dans l'union européenne et
dans d'autres formats et ce consensus
est appliquée quand les décisions sur
les sanctions surprise est donc comment
va réagir l'italie s'il ya d'autres
sanctions donc c'est pas tout à fait
quoi et c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura pas
d'autres de nouvelles sanctions si un
pays est contrainte donc nous savons qui
est le principe de solidarité
on se tient par la main comme on dit
mais je ne pense pas que l'italie soit
intéressé
renforcer la pression la confrontation
au contraire nous voyons la poursuite
comme je le dis de la politique
extérieure de la diplomatie italienne
notamment envers la fédération de russie
non pas de menaces est constamment ne
pas faire de déclarations sur des
punitions mais de chercher à trouver des
accords nous les avons dit aujourd'hui
que
sur le principe de l'indivisibilité de
la sécurité
sur lequel justement des discussions se
poursuivent aujourd'hui
qu'il faut que la russie cherche à
obtenir des garanties juridiquement
contraignante contraignantes donc
effectivement il ya cette composante qui
est importante c'est à dire éviter qu'un
pays aucun groupe de pays au sein de
l'organisation cherche à dominer dans
l'espace de l'ouest
et c'est exactement ce que fait l'otan
est un exemple tout à fait concret ça
date pas d'hier déjà en 2009 quand la
russie avait proposé le principe
que le principe d'indivisibilité la
sécurité soit au coeur d'un document
juridique après de longues queues
tentatives
cherchant à éviter une réponse il avait
dit à la rue on avait dit à la russie
que c'était éviter parce que les
garanties de sécurité ne peuvent être
fournis que dans le cadre de l'otan et
par personne d'autre en europe or c'est
une position très rothaine même
provocatrice parce que elle incite les
pays neutres
a frappé à cette porte cette fameuse
porte ouverte d'eau longtemps et nous en
avons parlé aujourd'hui
il ya l'article 10 le
président poutine en a parlé lors de sa
rencontre dans sa conférence de presse
avec le président macron ce n'est pas
que chaque pays par exemple l'ukraine
puisse demander à intégrer l'otan et
qu'il faut l'admettre
c'était le contraire c'était que tout
pays membre de l'alliance
sur la base du consensus
peut en anglais c'est mes
invités
un autre pays à se joindre à l'otan si
les critères nécessaires sont respectés
et si ce pays ajoute de la sécurité au
sein de l'alliance et il me semble ici
que c'est tout à fait clair qu'on
comprend bien de quoi il s'agit et si on
s'en tient à l'objectivité et qu'on
applique cet article 10 tel qu'il est
écrit
on voit très bien quelle sera la réponse
est en tout cas c'est notre position
nous en avait parlé aujourd'hui
en ce qui concerne votre question
keep up de savoir comment qu'on va
commencer la désescalade ce n'est pas
notre terme ce n'est pas nous qui
l'avons invitée ce sont les probas
candice qui l'avons utilisé c'est devenu
un cliché
sens
sans lui les usages de l'expression
préoccupation à propos de la d'escaladé
ya pas de déclarations faites par les
occidentaux
le 20 février c'est la fin des exercices
tels qu'ils ont été annoncés
est-ce que l' escalade va s'arrêter le
20 février je ne sais pas ce n'est pas
nous qui lavons gonfler
la
les diffuseurs connu deux informe des
informations sur la frontière
entre la russie et l'ukraine ont annoncé
pour hier justement une intervention qui
finalement apple
liste ross avait annoncé récemment
odieux
avait annoncé que cette augmentation des
tensions peut se prolonger encore
pendant des mois moi je sais pas donc la
question c'est pas nous qu'il faut la
poser
l'agent spoutnik
bonjour
j'ai fait plusieurs questions pour le
ministre est à l'air monsieur di maio
plus tôt le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères avait envoyé des lettres aux
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'ue et ce pour savoir comment ils
comprenaient les principe de
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité en
europe mais au lieu d'une réponse il ya
eu une réponse commune de l'union
européenne
donc ma question est ce que l'italie à
l'intention d'envoyer une réponse à
individuel à cette lettre du ministre et
comment l'italie perçoit le principe de
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité en
europe merci
merci le principe de l'indivisibilité de
la sécurité
c'est un principe qui fait partie de la
catégorie des principes que nous avons
toujours soutenu parce que à notre avis
c'est un principe fondamental de la
sécurité en europe
la sécurité
andy visible c'est l'idée que nous
soutenons c'est comme ça que nous voyons
le principe des activités du conseil
otan russie parce que c'est important
pour tout le monde part pour tous les
pays dont nous pouvons parler
la visite actuelle en russie c'est un
indice
de
du fait que nous cherchons une réponse
diplomatique aux questions qui sont
d'actualité aujourd'hui
nous agissons en fonction de nos
relations d'amitié et de coopération qui
ont toujours été ainsi
lagence nova c'est à vous la parole
monsieur le ministre
mardi vous avez été akiyev vous avez eu
une réunion avec le ministre collet bas
aujourd'hui vous avez cette réunion avec
monsieur lavrov quel a été le contenu de
ce qu'elle est le contenu de ce que vous
allez dire à vos collègues et vous
entourent le culte heures dans les jours
à venir deuxième question et pour
monsieur labro vous avez préparé une
liste des garanties de sécurité
vous avez évoqué comme impérative mais
l'occident paraît-il ne veut pas céder
aimez vous parlez de régler concret
possible quels sont les résultats
possibles
merci je voterai re souligné
comme je l'aï déjà fait plus tôt
dans le cadre d'une réunion entre le
ministre draghi le premier ministre
draghi nous avons tout fait pour que le
dialogue se poursuive c'est notre
objectif nous allons poursuivre le
dialogue avec nos alliés de l'otan
dans le cadre des principes
sur lesquels se base la politique
extérieure
de l'italie
à marge du sommet qui aura bientôt lieu
en afrique nous allons discuter
probablement de ces questions également
on va évoquer les moyens de parvenir à
décision pacifique de la crise je pense
que c'est le seul moyen qu'il faudrait
que l'ensemble des membres de l'union
européenne devraient suivre à munich
bientôt
il y aura la réunion des sept ministres
des affaires étrangères ce sera encore
une réunion où on aura la porte unités
de discuter de ces questions
aujourd'hui
après ce que nous avons discuté je vois
que la russie et l'ukraine sont prêts à
continuer cette conversation ce sera
donc le contenu
dont je parlerai les questions de la
sécurité européenne
est donc cette question elle est au
centre de nos réunions et sera au centre
de nos rayons
c'est le point de vue la position unie
unifier la recherche d'une décision de
telles solutions de paix
c'est pas tout à fait juste de dire que
la russie a proposé une liste de
questions de sécurité ce n'est pas la
russie qui a fait une liste de garantie
c'est à dire qu'il ya un document quêter
qui émane de l'oas yeux et du conseil
otan russie et cette
étape avait été entreprise en
[Musique]
1994 et il était dit clairement en 94
qu' aucun pays participants ne ferait
quelque chose qui puisse présenter une
menace pour un autre pays ensuite il y
avait l'acte fondateur après il y avait
lu la déclaration de rome et avant cela
le sommet de
d'istanbul et puis ensuite celui
d'astana
et que nous utilisons justement comme
base de notre initiative c'est dans
chaque pays a le droit de choisir son
alliance mais en même temps aucun pays
ne doit choisir une alliance qui doit
constituer une menace pour un autre pays
il ne doit pas assurer sa sécurité aux
dépens de celle des autres
donc il faut respecter les pays qui ont
choisi la neutralité c'est un point
important c'est intéressant de voir
justement
on voit les pays neutres
demandé à l'otan de s'occuper de la
sécurité c'est intéressant et bien aussi
un autre point c'est qu' aucun pays et
je vais déjà des groupes de pays ne peut
prétendre
dominer
l'espace de l'osce et aucun pays ou
groupes de pays ne doit pouvoir créer
une sphère d'influencé tout cela était
écrit tous ont été validées par les
présidents par les gouvernements diffusé
par l'onu et tout le monde était fier de
cette réussite
mais en matière de serre d'un flux ans
aujourd'hui on s'est souvenu de ce que
notamment les dirigeants de l'union
européenne avaient dire que la russie ne
devait avoir qu'une influence dans les
balkans elle n'avait aucune place là-bas
et monsieur borel avait dit par exemple
que en afrique la russie gène l'union
européenne
donc l'union européenne a droit d'avoir
des zones d'affluence mais la russie où
ses voisins n'a aucun le droit et c'est
pas seulement où les pays européens
veulent de pénétrer mais
mais concrètement pénétrer contre les
intérêts de la fédération de russie et
en parlant des balkans
il ya un représentant américain des
états unis pour les balkans
oui monsieur escobar
c'était peut-être un parent mais donc
monsieur escobar avait fait des
déclarations sur laquelle la serbie
devait cesser d'acheter du gaz à la
russie
elle devait trouver une alternative au
gaz russe
hélas encore eu une zone d' influence et
il fallait que la serbie casse ses
relations de confiance d'amitié avec la
fédération de russie et quand les
américains disent aux rhdp aux allemands
ou à d'autres européens que c'est pas à
eux de décider les questions de sécurité
donc et sur north stream ii par exemple
leur influx leur
ingérence ici donc il ils nous disent
c'est pourquoi vous promouvez vos
initiatives puisque rien ne menace notre
sécurité alors écoutez
respectons-nous les uns des autres et
laisser la russie
assurer sa sécurité elle même l'exemple
que je viens de citer est très
révélateur parce que
deux dans toute cette diversité et dans
toute cette complexité des composants
qui ont été validées au plus haut niveau
par leur seul
les pays occidentaux choisi ce que tel
ou d'un tel ou tel élément et quand on
reste il le ronnie et on voit la même
chose dans leur approche des accords
2000 ce qui on en a parlé aujourd'hui
les accords 2010 clairement
les mesures de sécurité le retrait des
armes lourdes l'aministie
le statut particulier du donbass qui
doit être entériné dans la constitution
ukrainienne via une réforme sur la base
de la décentralisation et en accord avec
donetsk est lougansk est encore une fois
sur la base de tout ça saoule à
l'organisation d'élections sous l'égide
de l'ouest et seulement ensuite quand
tout cela serait fait quand le droit des
gens de sept territoires qui se sont
levés contre
le coup d'état en ukraine ce qui leur a
valu d'être bombardés par toute l'armée
ukrainienne
quand tout cela sera fait et que leurs
droits seront garantis à ce moment là le
cren pourra rétablir son contrôle sur la
frontière toute la frontière entre le
cren et la russie comme inscrit mais le
contrôle de la frontière c'est l'acte
final or nos collègues occidentaux
aujourd'hui nous disent que les accords
de minsk nous sommes d'accord n'y a pas
d'alternative mais on va inverser
l'ordre de succession de ces éléments et
c'est ce que disait dance qui sait ce
qu'on dit prochain tout d'abord ils ont
dit donnez nous le contrôle la frontière
et ensuite on va gérer on trouvera
peut-être un statut pour le don de
bassoues y aura peut-être des élections
peut-être d amnistie
et dons à des projets de loi
invaincu des projets doit d'épuration
notamment
de poursuite pénale et c'est donc ici
vous voyez qu'on a
des craintes suffisamment sérieuse
et donc notre collègue a dit qu'il était
à kiev et je salue donc cette volonté
effectivement sincère d'aidé mais
monsieur le show cela dit lors de ses
discussions avec le président poutine
que zelensky
et il était à kiev avant
vendredi à moscou il avait dit que kiev
proposerait un certain nombre de
propositions de loi sur le statut sur
les amendements la constitution sur la
sur l'organisation des élections rien
n'a été fait et donc ces promesses ont
été officiellement désavoué pas des
hauts responsables à kiev et ir j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il ya vu une discussion
téléphonique entre monsieur buydens
should et et comme l' a officiellement
annoncé le gouvernement allemand ils ont
constaté que le retrait des armes russes
n'est pas constater qu'il est important
de lancer un dialogue constructif sur la
sécurité européenne de remplir les
accords de minsk et avec le soutien de
l'allemagne et de la france de d'obtenir
un un progrès dans l'accomplissement des
désaccords demi c est que la clé de tout
cela est à moscou or ça c'est malsain
c'est une tentative malsaine de fuir les
responsabilités
qui incombent et que et que les pays
occidentaux impose à le cren et rejeter
toute la responsabilité sur la russie
tout cela cette tactique cette stratégie
on la connaît mais elle ne rencontrera
aucun succès
les accords de minsk doivent être mises
en eux tels qu'ils ont été écrits
textuellement et le principe de
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité doit
être mise en place dans la pratique sur
la base de de garantie juridiquement
contraignante
la façon qu'il a été
validé par l'ouest
sur les discussions oui elles se
poursuivront sur tous les aspects de nos
propositions nous avons noté que dans la
deuxième partie de la réponse américaine
à d'autres initiatives
il y a elle accorde parler de tel ou tel
sujet de discuter sur les questions que
nous avons proposé que nous proposons
depuis plusieurs années en tant que
sujets prioritaires de discussions mais
il avait toujours fui ces discussions et
les accords sur
d'empêcher
le
déploiement d'armes offensives en europe
et notamment sur les lieux où ils
peuvent préparer ou où ces armes peuvent
constituer une menace pour la russie et
conclure un accord sur la baisse des
menaces militaires
en organisant des exercices conjoints
dans validant les voies de navigation
débattent des navires
les vols des avions et tout cela ils ont
refusé pendant ces trois dernières
années d'en discuter et dans la réponse
américaine justement ils ont dit qu'ils
étaient prêts à discuter de ce que nous
allions mais l'essentiel pour nous ce
n'est pas de retirer tel ou tel élément
de l'ensemble de ce paquet de mesures
est de dire ensuite que nous avons
résolu ces questions nous n'aurons nous
ne résoudrons pas ces questions tant que
nous n'aurons pas parler des questions
principales dont dépend la sécurité en
europe c'est la non extension de l'otan
vers l'est c'est le non déploiement
d'armes offensives et c'est le retour à
la configuration
politique et militaire de 1997 sur
l'acte fondateur des relations entre
russie et l'otan est à la base de notre
argument il y à ce que j'ai exposé en
détail aujourd'hui et précédemment sur
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité telles
que ça a été validé au plus haut niveau
et dont l'occident cherche à extraire
tel ou tel élément et aujourd'hui j'ai
demandé en particulier à nos amis
italiens c'est de ma demande
particulière que il ne se cherchait ne
se cache pas derrière tout un tas de
papiers on m'a envoyée stoltenberg et
bourrel m'envoyer des documents alors
que je leur ai rien demandé
mais les documents aloi ce n'ont pas été
signé ni à l'otan ni à lui ni il faut
pas aujourd'hui avec tous toute cette
paperasse
empêché de répondre aux questions que
nous brosser et faire en sorte que telle
ou telle organisation domine en europe
et par conséquent nous allons donc
poursuivre poliment mais instamment
demandé à nos collègues
qu'il réponde
au plan national
ouvertement sur ce qu'est pour eux le
résultat des documents qui ont été
signés à l'époque et qui n'ont été
annulée par personne et quelles sont
leurs intentions en matière de mise en
oeuvre de ces documents la question
finale par izvestia
une petite précision sous quelle forme
la russie at elle envoyé sa réponse
aujourd'hui aux américains ce sera une
note diplomatique à c'est ce que ça a
été déjà décidé nous avons l'intention
de l'envoyer sous forme écrite et
électronique comme vous le rendrai
public
dans quelques heures je pense
nous allons envoyer aux américains et à
ce moment là bas par les questions
principales à votre avis
les partenaires occidentaux on tienne
l'intention de s'excuser ou bien de
fêter leurs déclarations fausses sur
l'intervention en ukraine qui se
préparait quand pourront-ils le faire et
deuxième question pourriez vous donner
un commentaire sur la déclaration
récente de président zine ski il a dit
voir des signaux des possibles
négociations derrière son dos concernant
le cren les tensions entre la russie et
l'occident il dit ne pas prêter
attention à ces signaux parce que celui
c'est la vérité qui est avec eux m une
question pour monsieur dit mayer vous
avez visité un musée
à kiev avait l'intention de visiter une
ce genre de musée à moscou en ce qui
concerne
est ce que nos parents nos partenaires
ont honte ou pas ce qu'ils initient de
la calomnie en fait de la désinformation
et
se livre à
un terrorisme médiatique informationnel
je trouve pas d'autres termes je ne
pense pas que
il s'en repent un jour ou l'autre mais
cela se produit tous les jours on dirait
que ces derniers temps ça s'est accéléré
on nous a dit ce serait le le 15 février
le 7 février le favori et maintenant on
nous dit que ça peut être n'importe quel
jour et à ce moment là j'aurais eu
raison de faire tel ou tel pronostic
sur l'évolution des événements donc
c'est ça qu'on entend et c'est un petit
peu difficile de qualifier cette
pratique que je considère comme tout à
fait inacceptable de la part d'un
responsable politique ou diplomatique
donc cette tentative d'utiliser des
moyens peu honorable et ceux dont il
s'occupe
si on l'appelle pas si on qualifie pas
cela d' escalade
je vois pas où est le problème
chaque pays peut 2
organisé l'exercice sur son territoire
planté ses tentes en ramasser son
matériel repartir mais là où elle
dansait action où est le mal est
gonflé l'opinion publique avec ses
histoires terribles nous en avons parlé
aujourd'hui au renault sait par exemple
que sa façon de couvrir ces éléments ces
règles donc
cette chaîne qui se vante de son point
de vue équilibré
par conséquent
certains diffusent ce mensonge
procède de telles actions dans le dans
l'espace médiatique
d'autres cherchent le consensus la
solidarité et
comprennent bien ce qu'il se passe
mais dans cette fameuse politique de
consensus et de
solidarité d'oublier mais nous voyons
tout cela et on s'amuse même de on se
réjouit on
on leur donne pas du pain pour qu'ils
nourrissent l'horreur russophobie c'est
regrettable mais tous ces cris d'orfraie
ne seront pas utilisées comme
prétexte
ccc pseudo motif
de peur ne sont pas utilisés pour que
pour qu'il renonce à examiner nos
propositions qui repose sur ce qui a été
signé par tous les pays occidentaux dans
quatre de l'ouest et à l'époque
donc quand tu as qu est ce qui est fait
dans le dos de kiev vous savez
c'est peut-être pas juste s'exprime
ainsi qu'en tous nos partenaires
occidentaux ne font que cela
c'est-à-dire
souligné la nécessité de remplir les
accords de minsk et appelle la russie à
le faire mais en fait
il protège le il est pas au régime de
kiev de remplir ses obligations et dont
il faut pas s'inquiéter pour monsieur
zelensky
pour l'instant ni la france ni là ni les
états unis ni l'allemagne non influence
sur kiev mais j'espère qu'on sortira de
cette impasse et que
leurs paroles sur le fait que les
accords de minsk sont
sans alternative
et notamment des ctt d'attribuer ou dans
le bassin statut particulier j'espère
que tout cela sera réalisé
sur l'escaladent on nous a montré
la feuille publié hier et approuvé par
secrétaire général de l'otan et sur la
situation en ukraine et le texte dit
justement qu'ils sont préoccupés par les
agissements de la fédération de russie
et toutes ces menaces pour la sécurité
européenne et pour protéger notre
alliance nous
déployons des forces supplémentaires
dans la partie orientale de l'otan ainsi
que des troupes
navales et aériennes supplémentaires sur
l'arros la réponse au fait que les
militaires russes se trouvent sur leur
territoire
ne font de pénétration nul pas
nous n'augmentons pas du tout notre
présence
à la frontière des pays de l'otan et
l'otan fait justement ce dans quoi elle
nous accuse et une partie de cette
déclaration d'hier ils disent nous
sommes préoccupés
par
la présence militaire russe
augmenté
en ukraine
et en biélorussie que vous comprenez ça
comment vous là ce sentiment de
2,2 perfection ce sentiment de
supériorité
malheureusement est présent chez nos
collègues c'est tout je vous remercie
oui je vais répondre aussi à votre
question
c'est que
récemment nous avons annoncé l'année
croisée des musées
donc j'aurai l'opportunité de visiter le
musée de la victoire aussi
concernant d'autres questions je pense
que nous devrions nous devons appliquer
des efforts cros joie être activement
impliqués pour faire en sorte que le
dialogue continu et que la russie
retournent au travail dans le format du
conseil le temps russie
nous espérons que les conditions
actuelles nous permettront de le faire
la réponse unitaire à cette question
c'est une bonne chance pour que le
retour aux discussions et à une solution
de paix
je devrais expliquer nous serions
heureux de retravailler dans le conseil
russie otan
mais comme ce stoltenberg et ses
bureaucrates on commençait pas nous
interdire à nos diplomates et nos
militaires à bruxelles
comme tous les militaires et diplomates
des autres pays de travailler dans le
quartier général de l'otan ils ont
commencé à exiger que deux
nos diplomates s'inscrivent
pour demander à laisser passer deux
jours avant et pendant la présence au
siège de l'ond de l'otan tu
qu'ils soient toujours suivis surveillés
et les dernières fois comme monsieur
stoltenberg a exigé que
nous réduisions notre présence
et beaucoup de diplomates et militaires
avaient été déclarés comme inutile et 7
derrière sa dernière déclaration vais
demander que notre présent soit réduite
à 10 personnels militaires
diplomates et personnels techniques donc
personne ne peut nous n'avons pas voulu
jouer cette pièce de théâtre on a dit
que tout ne calmerait pas
nous l aurions notre présence est la
nôtre chez vous et la vôtre chez nous à
bruce et quand vous comprendrez que tout
cela va contre les intérêts de la
sécurité
de l'europe est bien quand vous aurez
fini quand vous aurez compris faites
nous signe
il ya la question des effectifs des
représentations il ya la question des
mécanismes
du conseil russie otan sur les problèmes
de l'afghanistan sur la lutte contre
terrorisme tout cela a été rayé
en un instant
quand les représentants de l'otan décidé
de soutenir le coup d'état
illégales en ukraine et soutenir tous
ceux
des condamnés tous ceux qui ont
[Musique]
et de condamner tous ceux qui vous qui
étaient contre ce coup d'état qui ont
voulu reprendre le pouvoir en crimée
donc tout cela c'est une une histoire
c'est à dire que on voulait nous
les américains voulaient se saisir de la
crimée et en faire une base militaire
mais donc je salue toute volonté de
reprendre les travaux du conseil aussi
autant je suis pour que ces travaux se
reprennent
dans leur volume complet normal
parce que après que
les l'otan a décidé de fermer ce système
j'ai considéré que c'était mauvais nous
espérons que cela reprendront
le travail que nous menons cette
direction devrais je crois nous
permettre de faire un saut très que le
conseil russie otan
reprenne ses activités
et
je pense que nous sommes d'accord et la
russie est d'accord que si ce conseil
travaille normalement ce sera une bonne
plateforme pour échanger nos opinions et
trouver des solutions pour satisfaire
les deux parties
merci
je